イツモ応援シテマス！
お～ありがと～
ほんとありがと～❤　いやいやこちらこそ～
英語もお上手なんですねっ❤︎
えー！ いやいや全然っすよー(汗)
一緒にセルフィー撮ってもいいかしら？
も、もちろんっすよ((* ´д｀*))
わ、吾輩をご存知なので？
もちろんですわ、HAJIME様でしょ❤︎
まじすか！ ｷﾀ━━(ﾟ∀ﾟ)━━!!!!
ありがとう❤　こちらこそ～
お会いできて光栄でしたわ❤︎
カメラマン：うっふっふ～
まぁ、気になります…
果たして、海外ではじめしゃちょーを
知っている人はいるのかという、企画です。
質問を考えたんですよ。こういう感じで。
「I'm a Japanese YouTuber」
だれかが分かんないから。そこをちゃんと説明したい。
カメラマン：Bigが消えてません…
ゼロトゥーワンフォーメックス（0124mex）
チャンネルのIDをちゃんと教えてあげる
シャキーン
登録してね、と
んで登録者数の数も書いておきました。
カメラマン：なんかフリップ芸人みたいっすよ
2人：はははは
でイエスかノーと。
カメラマン：オッケー、知ってる知らないっすね
ハーイ
誰か：That’s so nice（それいいね）
はじめん：We are Japanese YouTuber(俺たち日本のYouTuber)
Ah,Japanese!(あぁ！日本ね！）
もうここでやっちまおう
日本語わかんねーけどいい？
全然オーケーさ！
俺のこと知ってるか？
いやぁー
いやぁーー
いやぁーーー
( ﾟДﾟ)ﾊｧ??
情弱(´・ω・)ｽﾏｿ
コンニティワァ
はじめん：楽しめよ！　男：楽しめよ！
女性：写真いいかしら❤　はじめん：おっけ~
写真撮らせてもらっていいかしら~❤
俺のこと知ってる？
最近あなたの動画観たような気がするわ…
女性：Thank you~❤　はじめん：サンキュ~
はじめん：良い1日を～　女性：そちらこそ～❤
カメラマン：フリップ使わないんすか？
俺の英語が伝わらなさそうだったら使うよ。
カ：なるほどなるほど　は：今の感じでいけてたからさ。
Hello
は：おもしれぇな。　カ：ふふふふ
僕のことをご存知かな？
…知らん。
あぁ〜 ありがとねぇ〜 ( ? )
ちょいと失敬。
中であの「誰？」やる？
カメラ：涼しいっスね
あ～OK OK
あっ、あっ、
一つ質問しても良い？
ええ
マジで？
オ～！ｗｗｗｗ
おお、マジで？
おぉ、ありがとう
知ってたでござる〜(∩´∀｀)∩ｲｪｰｲ
ヘイユー！ 俺様と一緒に動画を録らないかい？
(・∀・)ｲｲﾈ!!
じゃあ俺様が質問して差し上げるぜ。
俺様はYouTuberなんだが…
おたくも？ (・∀・)ｲｲﾈ!!
もちろん知ってるよな？？
アタシがアタシのことを知ってるかって？
そりゃあ知ってますよ、アタシはアタシですから。
オラのこと知ってるぅ〜？
知らないわ… ごめんねボク。
そっかぁ… でもオラ平気だもん…
はいカット。
マジかw  おつかれーっす！^ ^
おつかれっした！ あざーす ^ ^
ありがとう。
日本でナンバーワンのYouTubeはじめしゃちょー